and finally new rule it's time to raise
awareness about a very serious problem
raising awareness we raise too much of
it
and it's
and it's making us crazy anxious and
depressed must we be sad about
everything all the time
most of which we can't do anything about
the ribbons the flags
the ads the hashtags it's like that
person on the plane in the next seat it
won't take a hint that you don't want to
talk
please i just want to look out the
window as the engine explodes
and since it's award season tonight i'd
like to introduce
this ribbon to raise awareness for the
growing epidemic of raising awareness
in march alone we are marking world
glaucoma week
national poison prevention week
international hpv awareness day and
world down syndrome day
march is also national colo rectal
cancer awareness month
brain injury awareness month bleeding
disorders awareness month and national
deep vein thrombosis awareness month
that's the month of march for you it
comes in like a brain injury and goes
out like deep vein thrombosis
oh and lest i forget this monday kicks
off world salt awareness week
a whole week to be aware of salt
i thought we were is there someone out
there thinking
why do restaurants always put the
cocaine right next to the pepper
we're so aware 24 7 of every bad thing
that could possibly happen that we've
completely run out of colors
purple is now the color for alzheimer's
lupus epilepsy fibromyalgia
whatever that word is and the opioid
crisis
i used to like that color now it scares
the [ __ ] out of me
everything you can buy now comes in a
pink version to raise awareness of
breast cancer including a pink
drill bit for fracking which is probably
giving us cancer
staples
[Applause]
staples sells pink breast cancer
awareness pens
paper clips scissors even a pink stapler
shaped like a ribbon
walking the aisles there is like a visit
to the cancer museum
am i a terrible person because i'd like
to buy office supplies without needing a
drink afterward
football players with pink shoes look
let me go on record and say i'm against
breast cancer but i'm trying to escape
for a few hours
can i just watch the game without
thinking about cancer
we've all heard about it
[Applause]
it's like it's like raising awareness
for death hey what's that black ribbon
for
death what's that it's when you're not
alive anymore would you like to hear
more
budweiser pulled their ads from this
year's super bowl and donate the money
to
raise awareness about covid which i'm
pretty aware of
hey budweiser you weren't put on earth
to raise my awareness you were put on
earth to lower it
humans need to zone out sometimes that's
why marijuana is popular
and meditating
it's not a privilege to take a break
from everyone else's problems it's an
imperative not every ad on tv needs to
chastise me for not doing enough because
i'm sitting around watching tv
i can't even watch the prices right
without thinking about cutting my dog's
balls off
crew members on the major airlines now
wear black lives matter pins during the
flight you know
you can support a movement without being
constantly reminded of it
can i just get a rum and coke and hold
the white guilt trip till we land
must we use every available platform as
an issue billboard
clothing commercials social media
sporting events award shows
milk i feel like this all started with
milk someone in the 80s looked at a milk
carton
and said what a waste not using milk as
a vehicle for missing children to plead
with you to put down the shredded wheat
and get out there and crack my cold case
hi
look i don't have a lab where i can cure
cancer
i'm not a pi and that's the part about
this stuff that bugs me
it's not actually doing something that
ribbon
isn't there to make me think so much as
to raise awareness of what a good person
you are
this is to activism what putting a flag
on your car is to patriotism
so in april please won't you join me for
a chill the [ __ ] out month
you